翻訳: Ryo Sugio
校正: Kyoko Kamura
みなさんは身近に
「自分とは性格が違うな」
って感じる人間がいますか
私はいます
私の夫 俊介です
私たち夫婦は２人とも
元気でお喋りなので
よく同じタイプの人間に
思われがちなんですが
実は 真逆の人間です
夫はポジティブで
基本的にやりたいことは
「絶対何とかなるから まず行動に移そう」
っていうタイプで
「死ぬこと以外かすり傷」
「生きてるだけで丸儲け」
そんな成功者たちの言葉を
体現したような人間で
実際に 数年前
交通事故で死にかけました
そのとき夫は 脊髄損傷を負い
車いすでの生活を
余儀なくされましたが
その後も前向きに 自分がやりたいことに
どんどんチャレンジしています
一方で私は
とてもネガティブな人間です
私だって彼のようにやりたい事をやって
後悔しない人生の方が素敵やなって
そう思います
だけどその一歩が 踏み出せません
リスクばっかりに目がいって
かすり傷をすることさえ怖い
そう感じてしまいます
こんな真逆の性格ですから
普段 喧嘩も本当に多いんです
これは数ヶ月前
夫からいきなり私に送られてきた
チャットの内容です
（笑）
スキーを経験したこともない夫が
「スキーでパラリンピック目指したいから
フランスに修行に行かしてくれ！」
そんな内容でした
私は「いや また脊髄損傷になるよ」と
ケガのリスクを考えて
猛反対するんです
そうすると
夫は言い返してきて
私も言い返して
最終的に言い争いになるんですよね
もういつもこんな感じで
喧嘩ばっかりしてるので
極力 共同作業を避けてきた
私たちなんですが
それでも一緒にチャレンジしてることが
１つだけあります
それがこの「Re:Walk Project」です
このプロジェクトは２年前
交通事故で 夫が
歩けなくなったことをきっかけに
夫婦でクラウドファンディングで
立ち上げたプロジェクトです
現在の日本の病院では
一度 脊髄損傷で
完全麻痺と診断されると
一般的には車いすを前提にした
リハビリになります
それでも諦めきれなかった私たちは
歩くための再生医療とか
リハビリの情報を集めて
それを同じ思いを持つ
できるだけ多くの人に届けるために
このプロジェクトを立ち上げました
結果 このプロジェクトでは
525名の支援をいただいて
540万円を資金として集め
Webサイトを作ったり
今年４月には 200人規模の
イベントを主催するなどして
情報発信の活動を続けてきました
このプロジェクトをきっかけに
Yahoo!ニュースに掲載いただいたり
オーストラリアにある
グリフィス大学にある
再生医療の研究所にご招待いただいたり
研究の一環として
筑波大学附属病院のHALを利用した
治療の機会をいただきました
私はこの挑戦を通じて
「挑戦をすればチャンスを
つかむことができるんや！」って
そう体感しました
20年間サッカーを続け
「命の次に大切な足」
そう言ってた夫にとって
この事故は本当に辛い出来事でしたが
夫は命を助けてくれたお医者様
周りのサポートに感謝しながら
常に前向きにリハビリに取り組みました
そして「無理と言われても
納得がいくまでリハビリを続けたい」
そう言って彼は最終的に
オーストラリアでのリハビリを決めました
一方で私は 夫の事故後も
とてもネガティブな考えが
頭の中を駆け巡っていました
オーストラリアでの
リハビリを決めたときも
不安の方が先にありました
だけど このオーストラリア行きを
提案したのは
実は夫ではなくて
私だったんです
実はこのプロジェクトは
私たち夫婦の真逆の性格が功を奏した
と言っても過言ではありません
夫は前に進む力はあるんですが
リスクヘッジが苦手です
私はリスクヘッジのために
とことんリサーチしまくります
歩くための情報を
毎日ネットで検索しまくって
病院宛てに手紙を書いたり
海外の友人にヒアリングするなどして
海外のリハビリ情報にたどり着きました
これまでも ネガティブやったからこそ
人生の選択肢を広げることができました
大学は４年間 アメリカに留学
今年は 友人と会社も立ち上げました
そう ネガティブであっても
チャレンジすることはできるんです
ネガティブな私が挑戦をするとき
いつも 大切にしていること
それが今回お話しする —
「おまけをもらいにいく」という発想です
さて ここからが本題です
皆さんはこんな経験ありませんか
小さいとき
自分の好きなキャラクターの
シールやカード おもちゃなど
おまけのついたお菓子を
ついつい買ってしまったっていう経験
買う気がなかった雑誌とか漫画を
一緒についてる付録が魅力的で
買ってしまったよっていう経験
それ以外にも
「今なら入会金無料」とか
「１つ買うと もう１つおまけ」とか
こんなおまけが決め手になって
何かを買った 決断した
そんな経験ないでしょうか
「いやぁ この値段やと買われへんけど
こんなええ事が付いてくるのはお得やな」って
このように おまけは
一見ハードルが高いと思われる商品の
購入をするモチベーションを作り出したり
人の決定の後押しをしてますよね
何をするにもネガティブで
一歩が踏み出せない私は
この「おまけ」をたくさんもらいに
行くことを 常に意識してます
では「おまけをもらいに行く」って
どういうことでしょうか
例えば 挑戦して得たいもの
やりたいことがあったとします
今回の夫が挑んだ
海外のリハビリのケースだと
「歩けるようになる」
っていうのがこれですよね
でも もしこれで失敗したら
つまり 夫が海外のリハビリで
歩けなかったとしたら
このとき得られる価値がゼロになる
そう普通考えますよね
「時間やお金かけたのに
得られるものがゼロ
自分の挑戦って
無駄になってしまうかもしれん」
でもそうすると 足がすくんで
一歩が踏み出せなくなります
そこで私は この「歩ける」という
成果以外に得られるもの
この挑戦でどんなおまけが
もらえるかっていうのを
具体的に想像してくんです
例えば 海外でリハビリすることで
海外に友達ができる
海外にリハビリとか再生医療の
情報ネットワークができる
海外と日本のリハビリとか
医療の違いを知ることができる
夫の英語力アップ！など
これら この挑戦で得られるおまけを
次々想像してくことで
何かこの挑戦の価値が
大きくなった気がしませんか
１つの目標を目指して
「こんなにいいことあるんやったら
ちょっとやってみてもいいかも！」って
そんな気持ちになりませんか
ちなみに私は先ほど ４年間
大学 アメリカに留学したと言いましたが
留学を決断したときも
このおまけの発想を使いました
「将来は世界を駆けめぐる
キャリアウーマンになりたい！」
「アメリカンドリームや！」
そんな生意気な夢を
小学生のときから語ってた私は
ずっとアメリカ留学を夢見てました
いろいろ不安はありましたが
得意のリサーチで
都心に比べて
学費も比較的安くて
治安面も安心できて
なおかつ留学生の
スカラーシップ制度が整っていた—
アラバマにある大学を
夢の留学先として選びました
私が行った場所は
とても小さい町だったんですけども
それでも「英語を学びたい」
「アメリカで勉強したい」という
私の夢を叶えるには
十分な環境でした
それでも「親にこんなに
お金かけてもらったのに
失敗したらどうしよう」
「卒業できんかったらどうしよう」
そんなプレッシャーに
押しつぶされそうになったとき
私はふと
「この挑戦で自分が得られるものを
考えてみよう」って そう思いました
「いやー アラバマに行った
日本人ってめっちゃ珍しい」
「今後グローバルで働く自分の
特長になるかもしれない」とか
アラバマって南部なんで
「アメリカ南部の色濃い歴史や
文化を勉強できるぞ」とか
「小さい町だからこそ いろんな人と
仲良くなって何かできそう」とか
そうやって行く前から
アラバマについて調べて
自分の得られるおまけを
どんどん想像していくと
何か自分の挑戦が
お得な気さえしました
そしてとんでもなく
ワクワクしたことを覚えてます
私は夫に海外のリハビリを提案したとき
実はこんなふうに考えてました
「失敗するのは怖い
だけど どうせやるんやったら
おまけもらいに行こう」って
障がいでできないことに
目が行きがちだからこそ
夫にできることを
増やしてあげたい
何かやろうとするとき
どうしても失うもんばっかりに
目が行ってしまいます
そして不安が重なって
いつしか やらない理由ばかりを
考えてしまうようになります
でもそんなとき
いかに自分が挑戦しやすくなる環境を
自分で作り出せるか
挑戦からたくさんのおまけを
見つけてこられることを
どんだけ楽しめるか
それが ネガティブなりに挑戦して
チャンスをつかむための
私なりの考え方の工夫です
さて 今 夫はオーストラリアでの
リハビリを終えました
夫は歩けるようには
なりませんでした
だけど 毎日何時間も
リハビリをして
足の膝下を自分で動かせるという
奇跡的な回復を見せました
また たくさんのおまけを抱えて
日本に帰ってきました
英語力もアップし
現地に一生の友達と呼べる
存在ができました
砂浜の上を車いすで移動できる
ビーチマットに出会い
事故後 初めて海に入りました
そして「オーストラリアに
歩いて またみんなに会いに来る」
そんな 新たな夢ができました
世界には一緒に頑張っている仲間がいる
それを知ることができた夫は
世界中１人で どこへでも出かけて
先月 私への宣言通り
本当にフランスに行って
チェアスキーを始めました
夫はこれから チェアスキーで
パラリンピックを目指して
自身の経験を通じて
チェアスキーの楽しさを
世界中の子どもたちに教えたいそうです
夫のリハビリに付き添って
オーストラリアに行ったことで
私もまた たくさん
おまけをもらいました
美しいビーチが見られる
最高の環境で
夫婦でともに時間を
過ごせただけでなく
日本にいなくても
できる仕事を見つけました
ゴールドコーストマラソンで
人生初のハーフマラソンに挑戦しました
ヨガの聖地バイロンベイに行って
ヨガ修行しました
そこでもまた 世界中からの
素敵なヨガ仲間たちとの出会いがありました
ヨガの経験を生かして
トレーナーの指導の元
夫のリハビリを手伝えるようにもなりました
そしてまた私にも
現地に一生の友達ができました
夫の事故を通じて
たくさんの人に出会い
その出会いの中から
新しい居場所を見つけ
今もやりたいことを見つけては
「１つの挑戦から たくさんの
おまけをもらいに行くこと」
それをモットーに
挑戦の場を広げています
石橋を叩きまくって前に進む
ネガティブモンスターの私と
ブルドーザーのように前に突進する
ポジティブモンスターの夫
お互いスタイルは違えど
前に進んでることは確かです
そして こんな真逆の性格の私たちでも
共通していることが
１つだけあります それは
結局 自分がやるって決めたら
たとえ 失敗する可能性が高くても
その道は「正しかった」って言えるように
全力投球してることです
何かやろうとするとき
自分の選択が最善の選択かどうかなんて
そのときはわかりません
というか やって終わるまで
わからないもんだと思います
夫が事故で歩けなくなったとき
私たち夫婦は ある約束をしました
それは「この事故のせいで」ではなくて
「この事故があったからこそ
今 幸せなんや」って
そう言えるような
人生にしようって
そのために 無理と言われても
限界まで歩くことにチャレンジしようって
そう決めてからの私たちは
本当に必死でした
応援してくれる人の
期待を裏切らないように
そして 自分自身を裏切らないように
自分の選択や挑戦に責任を持つ
それはポジティブもネガティブも
関係ありません
大きなことはできなくても
自分のできることを地道にやって
そして最後に「自分の挑戦には
こんなに価値があった」って
そう言えること
その学びこそが 本当に自分にとっての
おまけなんやって思います
さて こんなに臆病で
自信のない私が
なぜ今日 ここに立つって決めたのか
今日こんなに良いチャンスを
いただいたのに
うまく話せんかったらどうしようって
当初はそんな恐怖が
私を襲いました
だけど
今日 うまく自分の思うように
ここで話せなかったとしても
私は あるおまけがあると思って
今日ここに立ってます
それは ここに立って話すことは
間違いなく私のトークスキル向上に
役立ったということ
このトークの原稿を作るにあたって
事故からこれまでの活動と意味を
改めて整理できたこと
「自分のネガティブは悪いもんじゃない」
そう自分の弱さをポジティブに
受け止められたこと
ここの会場にいる人
たった１人でもいいから
「何か新しいことに挑戦してみよう」って
そうやって思ってもらえること
TEDxKobeに関わらなければ
出会えなかった人がここにいるっていうこと
そして最後に 事故からこれまで
私たち夫婦をいろんなところで
支えてくれた人たちに
ありがとうを伝えられることです
本当に ありがとうございました
（拍手）